just there's all of this history and all
of this intrigue and a lot of
supernatural stuff that is hidden
beneath the surface that would otherwise
seem like it's all camp songs Zelda
Williams is one of the stars of free
forms news summer camp series dead of
summer premiering Tuesday night she
opened up to et about landing her first
leading role and the onset advice her
father Robin Williams passed down to her
this is really like your moment I mean
what was the audition process like and
and why this role the audition process
was very long and very interesting I did
this role because I think it needs to be
done I'm grateful that it took such a
long time for me to have someone decide
to choose me for something like this
because I got to grow up and I got to
find myself before having to find a
character that's so distant from myself
and that's really helpful I mean it
helps keep me certainly grounded more in
to reality I think you can lose it
otherwise you grew up in this industry
anything that you learned maybe watching
your dad on set or so long that you that
you took with you into this role he
always said don't wear your mic pack to
the bathroom the handy advice I'd say
that was the most pressing one don't do
that ever if your mics don't go anywhere
or say anything that you don't want
other people to hear because there's
probably like 30 people with headsets on
listening Zelda plays drew and promises
a roller coaster first season but drew
is a big mystery
I'm keeping secrets that even my other
cast mates aren't forced to keel because
my character is a secret in and of
itself that's very strange what can you
tell me about these ghosts that some
characters could possibly be seen
definitely not alone and there's a lot
of Secrets and there's a lot of people
are very haunted by many different
things any romance that we can
anticipate
hello today oh you give us a hint no I'm
not allowed you can get me in so much
trouble I mean it's the TV show we're
made any fun if no one had any romance